l'orégon devient le premier état
américain à voter pour la
décriminalisation des drogues dures et
je n'arrive pas y croire j'ai l'un des
organisateurs de la campagne
référendaire
59% des citoyens ont dit oui à la mesure
110 pour que la possession d'une petite
quantité de drogue dure ne soit plus un
crime
la mesure adoptée propose de
décriminaliser la possession simple soit
1 grammes ou moins d'héroïne 2 grammes
ou moins de cocaïne ou de
méthamphétamine et 15 grammes ou moins
de champignons psychoactifs ouais t'as
chine a actuellement une règle on se
fait reprendre avec une telle quantité
de drogue peut mener à un en prison et
six mille 250 $ d'amande la mesure 110
prévoit plutôt une amende de 100 $ ou
une évaluation médicale dans un centre
de traitement et surtout aucun casier
judiciaire
les économies dans le système carcéral
il y revenus tirés du cannabis devrait
rapporter environ 100 millions de
dollars pour différents programmes
sociaux au pays
c'est le genre de mesure que réclame
l'association canadienne des chefs de
police
ça fait des années qu'on congo la
possession simple de drogue puis ça
améliore la situation en août dernier la
directrice des poursuites pénales du
canada a ordonné aux procureurs fédéraux
de ne plus déposer d'accusations
criminelles pour la possession simple de
drogues dures expliquant que
l'efficacité des sanctions criminelles
étaient limitées reste à voir si le
gouvernement fédéral acceptera d'ouvrir
le débat qui si vincent maison devrait
au canada montréal